what are the most powerful conversation
you've seen on the app you mentioned
like people connecting
the hard part about that is the sorting
you know figuring out which one which
one am i going to put at the top
mental sorting out just something to
stand out to you sorry i don't mean to
do like the top 10 conversations ever of
all time
ever on the app i just mean like stuff
that you remember that stands out to you
i remember this one really amazing
comment
from this he was a mexican
international student who spoke out
and this this this post was super edgy
but yet it got hundreds and hundreds of
upvotes within the yale community it was
a yale community specific post and we
should point out that there's
a school community now and there's an
all-ivy community
so this was specifically in the yale
community and this was a little while
ago
but it stuck with me this mexican
international student comes to yale and
he starts talking about his experience
in the um la casa which is the mexican
latinx as they would say cultural center
at yale and how
he doesn't feel welcomed there because
he's
roman catholic basically and
international
and how he doesn't feel like he fits
with their agenda
and as a result this place that's
supposed to be home for him he feels
outcasted and feels more alone than he
does anywhere else on campus
that's powerful that was powerful to me
yeah it's hearing someone
someone who should be feeling supported
by this culture
say actually this is not doing anything
for me
like this is not helping me yeah this is
this is not where i feel
at home
you